on an actual friday finally we did it
did we actually what day is it today nah
probably not all right
[Music]
in five years i will place a flag for
pewds in antarctica i'm not joking five
years i can't wait five years
in five years i'm just not old enough
also i can go right now if my parents
did allow it what
no
no no no no we ain't got time i need
antarctica now someone else some
norwegian is gonna snoop it up otherwise
i appreciate the effort and
big peep before masculinity effort but
nah you know you know you know they're
going to swoop in those slimy slimers
basically video means knowledge in india
and a very famous girl named mr
took down the last video
poor video youtubers trying to make a
living
why are you roasting yourself scythe why
you've done nothing to deserve this stop
it
yes when
why is it always let's get side race
what about getting pewdiepie raised huh
let me give me a little bit of drip
okay
huh can i get a little bit
please pewter gets buff rigor's beard
has 110 million army claims antarctica
his viking ancestors watching from
it
antarctica is mine say it with me say it
loud say it proud
it's been eight month animating trying
to get this finished i know the clip
ain't relevant anymore oh it's the
classic with oh beautiful i got i can't
wait to watch
oh my god
no yeah
[Music]
listen
hey listen i'll just stay here
and you just walk away i don't i won't
tell i won't tell anyone whoa i love
this style i swear all right i'll i'll
be back and
damn
still here okay i will be of course
thank you thank you so much all right i
won't forget this
[Laughter]
oh burns all right thank you for doing
that i love it huge peepee absolutely no
ah it hurts when everything in life
doesn't matter anymore i hate it
stop it
oh man
hey we got the fan art felix schenberg
owner of antarctica
that you see that uh certificate
110 million pieces okay do you
understand i will share
i am generous leader of adult again
[Music]
oh my god
yeah good ken
god you're still both
here he comes
oh you like
where should i put his hand where should
i put his hand uh grab those packs grab
those nips
oh i know which game this is
it took me a sec
is that one yeah it's the buff what
that's great love that that was a fun
video did you know you can skip youtube
ads without ad blockers and or youtube
premium click the
circ uh-huh then click stop seeing this
ad don't tell anyone it's my room what
that's sick
don't do that i need money i'm money i
want money
it's okay you can do it if you want i
get it
my money no
if i had a nickel for every time felix
abandoned his minecraft series i have
two nickels which isn't a lot but it's
sad that it happened twice right three
actually
here it comes there is another
bro am i supposed to just play every
game forever guys you need to let things
go okay you have severe
if you guys were an entity or a person
you'd have severe separation anxiety you
understand that right i can't make
things last forever i'm sorry the beauty
of life is not bounding yourself to
things have freedom to explore new
things
go out there try different things i'm
doing it yeah computers have legs my
whole life was delay
no those are my hands ah wrong caption
oopsy i wonder if my toe healed
lovely
extra lovely toe
happy birthday to this chad if today is
your birthday martial check what's that
what
oh it's austin oh he told me about this
[Music]
she drinking like out of my glass or
something
[Music]
i wanted that
what is that
oh god
[Music]
that's awesome that's a cool match oh
jesus christ it's good thing horror
doesn't scare me anymore because
otherwise i'd be totally jump scared
right now that's sick what is it i love
that that's so cool he's been working on
this for months all the weird sound
effects came from real furbys yeah
that's cool if youtube won't do scare
pewdiepie maybe fans will need to create
frightened felix oh
forgot about that there are no
reasons they're planning something i
know it they're taking all the pasta i
know it they're trying to compensate for
losing antarctica budget child babies so
immature come on norwegians
this is low
this is a marxist your whatsapp isn't it
it's been a while
mariah
hey
it's done
yes
she agrees it's a fact
norway pewds denmark stinky denmark
don't think you can get away from me
denmark either you're next okay
coming for you next the peepee of the
pea if you know what i mean he purchased
uh rainforest for preservation epic
never heard of him if you went at the
river then where the
i'm in norway right now
see you have to be an alcoholic to enjoy
being in norway totally makes sense
don't need to watch anything more
no don't
no don't say it
all right that's slander
slander report for hate speech
report for hate speech and uh i feel
good things still threatening isn't
already a thing
oh oh god the truth you speak the truth
oh jesus
[Laughter]
tell me youtube
that was fun forgot about that some fan
art oh i love it cool colors thank you
shrimp paint they're very nice
oh my
god he's really young here
kind of fat too
no offense maya
she's like what the hell
oh
so cute
yeah you came to me yes hello hello
what's up
this is back in the day when she liked
both of us then she made her choice she
hates me okay i'm curious where this is
going antarctica is at the bottom of the
world correct pewdiepie claimed
antarctic true no
well
no no no no no no the logic adds up
there's no up and down in space right
everyone knows this floor gang can still
be floor gang no wait floor gang is a
good one oh my god i'm so stupid edit
that inside yeah
floor
the ultimate floor we will be the floor
of this nation we will be the floor of
the universe the world itself referring
to pewds and he's pretty much just made
a video blasting me i mean you're
putting out all this positive content
you're dark don't forget you're darman
everyone loves you
all right all right listen let's not
make a whole tea against darmian i don't
think it's just fun all right
hell yeah
hell yeah blitz platypus love it my
beautiful thumbnails it all makes sense
wait there's more ah beautiful
oh he okay yeah i'll use i'll use it
i'll use it
at least in another parallel universe
edgar isn't sleepy yes and there's also
a universe where you're funny damn me
such a good line from stephen hawking
but he doesn't even believe in all
parallel universe you put you fakers
maker stephen hawking come on pete's
life at ninja for this tweet i can't
stop thinking about time alternative
realities the infinite universe that is
constantly expanding all disappeared yes
listen
yes you're all right
i am cringing like ninja
no one should be surprised
buying part of antarctica officially
claiming part of antarctica from the u.n
saying antarctica is yours until it is
yours say it loud say it proud floor
army nation
antarctica ours
isn't it kind of annoying like you're
bored now everything already established
no more wars
lame why can't i claim antarctica it's
mine no one took it you forgot about it
that's your fault
dummy hell yeah we're right there at the
bottom this could be us at the bottom
and dart to get game so if we're gonna
claim all right hear me out all right so
the problem uh with no one claiming that
part of antarctica is because it's very
far away right yeah does this make sense
okay so the problem is you'll probably
have to go to like south uh africa or
something no no no you have to go to
what is that chile maybe and then you
have to take a boat across
and then the problem is that to get to
this area you know you'd have to either
go all the way around or you have to go
here and then all the way being you know
but my plan go to new zealand
swim
all the way here then just touch it
literally i'm just gonna touch it i'm
gonna swim with my flag
and then
right at the shore mine that's the plan
right now but i'm obviously you know
we're exploring options yeah i think it
could work introducing a la giska
gigante a scale worm that lives in
antarctica on second thought maybe we
won't swim maybe i'll wear like this
suit like diver suit and i'll walk at
the bottom of the sea floor
and i'll have a machine gun just in case
i bump into any of the giant devil
squirrels that exists
what a great pun love it the sims said
you guys are weird people who
know people who don't know this is
that's when he almost did the rooney
there you go
swedish youtuber who is known for owning
antarctica my claim to fame let's get it
gamers let's get into our thing let's
raid antarctica every masterpiece has
its cheap copy true
true word all right happy friday
everyone thank you for watching another
friday with pewdiepie
mental brofist
see you guys tomorrow
bye bye
you're browsing the internet
unsecurely
in nor the vpn
bonus say it with me
i got you the deal of century you get a
huge discount on a two-year plan with a
bonus of one to four additional months
for free but felix what is vpn vpn helps
you securely browse the internet they
restrict no logs policy it's out of
their business basically nothing will be
tracked and collected and you can do
whatever you want baby it's all right
you can tell me it helps you stay safe
not just for your own internet but also
if you're browsing a public wi-fi it's
pretty much a standard way to protect
yourself from people snooping and
stealing your passwords and private
information which can easily be done
otherwise your vpn is also available on
your phone if you connect a public wi-fi
with that or anything else but also one
of the greatest things about nordvpn is
that you can browse anywhere in the
world watch and download and get the
most out of your subscription services
with different kind of shows it's just
super handy to have when you need it i
was always that time when oh let's watch
that show oh it's not out here yet
yeah skip all that baby you're done and
i also think it's important to have a
wide and open internet so thank you
nordvpn for making that possible they
also have nordpass which is a password
manager that helps you store all your
passwords safely and also make better
passwords highly recommend that as well
so yeah take control of your internet
again with nordvpn and get an additional
bonus
for free nordvpn.com pewdiepie enter
code pewdiepie you are welcome get a
huge discount you are welcome